in order to avoid an economic and
financial catastrophe by defaulting
Democrats and Republicans have to agree
to raise the debt ceiling by early June
the negotiations are ongoing there's no
agreement we're still a part I've done
my part
but what if there were options for the
White House to go around Congress to
avoid a default even if they're not
better ones if Congress does not address
the debt limit there are no good options
the treasury or the government can use
to save us from catastrophe any
deviations from that path would be
highly risky highly risky and highly
unlikely but some are really being
considered I think it is worth taking
seriously you know they're all bad but
how they compare to the Badness of
default here are the three risky
unlikely but not improbable paths Biden
could take to avoid a default
let's start with the first one the
trillion dollar coin a bill in the 90s
aimed at making it easier to Mint
commemorative coins technically does say
that the treasury secretary can mint and
issue Platinum coins in any denomination
so the thought is why not Mint one for
one trillion dollars and then have
enough money to not need to take on more
debt I think the platinum coin is the
most unlikely Jason Furman was President
Obama's top Economist and was at the
White House during the first big debt
ceiling crisis I remember in 2011 I read
about the platinum coin on a blog post
someone sent me I went to Tim Geithner
who was then treasury secretary just in
the hallway before a meeting and said
hey what do you think of the platinum
coin he's like the Platinum what and I'm
like oh the platinum coin we can mint a
platinum coin he's like yeah what are
you talking about that's crazy the
current treasury secretary feels
similarly it's really a gimmick the
treasury also can't just mint the coin
and automatically start spending they
would need money in what is essentially
their checking account which is held at
the Federal Reserve and so you would
need them to bring that trillion dollar
coin to the Federal Reserve the Federal
Reserve to accept it and then credit the
government's checking account with a
trillion dollars and then the federal
government could use that money but it's
not clear the Federal Reserve would even
accept the coin there are no rabbits to
be pulled out of hats here this only
happens I know you don't like yes or
no's but if you were sent a trillion
dollar coin and asked to be asked to
treat it as a trillion dollars will you
treat it as a trillion dollars
that would be a rabbit coming out of a
head
the second but slightly more likely
option is the treasury issuing premium
bonds the way the treasury takes on debt
in the first place is by selling bonds a
thousand dollar ten-year bond with a
three percent interest rate also called
a coupon rate would pay thirty dollars
every year for 10 years so it's really
worth thirteen hundred dollars by the
way these interest payments are one of
many government expenses that are due
regularly and if the treasury doesn't
have enough money to pay them like they
say they won't if the debt ceiling isn't
raised by the X date around June 1st
that's a default the world has never
doubted that America will pay the
principal and interest on its bonds a
default would crack open the foundations
upon which our financial system is built
the treasury auctions off bonds and
maybe gets eleven hundred dollars for
that thousand dollar Bond they've
brought in an extra hundred dollars in
Revenue
when the debt ceiling is hit they aren't
allowed to take on new debt by issuing
new bonds but they could re-issue bonds
if an old thousand dollar bonds term is
ending they could put that Bond back up
for auction it's not new debt but they
could reissue with a higher coupon rate
say 10 percent then the bond would be
worth two thousand dollars over ten
years
it could bring in more money at auction
to fund the government without
technically taking out new debt even the
proponents of premium bonds would admit
that they are a bad idea compared to
raising the debt limit launching a brand
new type of bond that pays a very high
coupon payment so it has a lower face
value in the middle of a financially
turbulent period would be a real recipe
for a lot of financial Market chaos now
you do need to compare that chaos to the
chaos you would get if you went past the
X date and started not paying your
obligation so this becomes a you know
comparison of different forms of poison
the third and most likely option you
could call it the most likely option but
I'd rather call it the least unlikely
option okay the least unlikely option
would be to use the 14th Amendment
article one of the Constitution says
Congress has the power to pay the debts
of the US
but the 14th Amendment says the validity
of the public debt shall not be
questioned which could be interpreted to
mean the debt limit itself is
unconstitutional say you know what we
can issue whatever debt we want we're
not going to invent some brand new coin
we're not going to invent some brand new
type of debt we're just going to go
ahead and continue to issue debt this is
something the White House is really
looking into I've been considering the
14th Amendment the problem is it would
have to be litigated if you did the
invoke the 14th Amendment and financial
markets thought you had a good enough
chance of prevailing they would continue
to lend you money and so you'd be buying
yourself time
it might be that the courts supported
the theory of the 14th Amendment the
problem is you may not get that outcome
you may get the opposite and then you're
back to the drawing board with having
created a bunch of chaos but even if the
14th Amendment is an invoke now it might
be for future debt limit battles I'll be
very blunt with you and we could buy
this I'm thinking about taking a look at
months down the road is to see whether
what the court would say about whether
or not the it does work also One path
house Democrats not the White House
could take is something called a
discharge petition basically if speaker
McCarthy refuses to bring a clean debt
ceiling raise to the house floor a
majority of members could bring it to
the floor after a lengthy process it's
in the works but many experts say this
isn't highly likely either discharge
petitions rarely succeed and when they
do working through the process can take
more than a month and we do not have
more than a month to resolve this issue
which is why those in charge of the
country's Financial system say there's
only one way forward here and that is
for Congress to raise the debt ceilings
so that the United States government can
pay all of its obligations when due the
only good outcome is one in which
Congress act acts to raise the debt
ceiling